اعلن رئيس الجمهوريه القرم الموالي لروسيا
اليكسي اوكسينوف اسقاط مسيره اوكرانيه
حاولت القيام بهجوم على الجهه الغربيه من
شبه الجزيره من جانبه اعلن حاكم مدينه
سيفاستوبول ميخائيل روز ان اسطول البحر
الاسود بدعم من الدفاعات الجويه تصدى
لهجوم اوكرانيا بالمسيرات على المدينه
وانا مسيره واحده على الاقل اسقطت
معنى من موسكو مراسله الجزيره بابا وولد
حرمه ومن ميكو لايف مراسل الجزيره تامر
صمادي وابدا معك بابا ولد حرمه
بالخبر الهجوم على
مسيرات اوكرانيه كما تقول القوات المواليه
لروسيا ماذا في التفاصيل وهل من موقف روسي
بشان هذا الهجوم
نعم حسن لحد الان المتوفر من الانباء هو
ان هناك مسيرتين على الاقل حول الهجوم على
شبه جزيره القرم الاولى اسقطت في المنطقه
الغربيه من الجزيره اما الثانيه فكانت
تتجه الى مدينه
جاء على لساني رئيسي جمهوريه القرن
المواليه لروسيه
وكذلك على رئيس على لساني
حاكمان ياتيان بعد يوم واحد من هجوم كان
اول من امس في اول امس على شبه الجزيره
بالتحديد على مدينه صفرو واستهدف مخازن
للوقود وموده النفطيه ونجم عنه حريق كبير
استمر لعده ساعات قبل اخماده بشكل نهائي
وفقه ما علينا حكم مدينه صفا ستوبل
الموالي لروسيا طبعا الهجوم اول امس تقول
السلطاتها المحليه هناك انه لم يخلف اي
خسائر بشريه ولا اضرارا بالبنيه المدنيه
في المدينه الى هذا الهجوم الذي كان ولا
امس في
وكذلك هجوما اليوم في شمال غرب روسيا
فاننا سنجد خيطا ناظما هو استهداف هذه
مواد الطاقه لنقل الهجوم مثلا في بيانس
استهدف
يستهدف خطا لامداد الكهرباء عالي التوتر
الهجومي
يستهدف ايضا
قطار كان يحمل الشحنه وقود اذا هي هذه هي
الهجمات خلال الايام الاخيره سواء هناك في
جزيره القرم او سواء في المقاطعات الواقعه
في شمال غربيه روسيا تستهدف مواد الطاقه
وتستهدفه امدادات الوقود وكذلك امدادات
الكهرباء لحد الان لا تصيح رسميا روسيا
هنا في موسكو بشان هذا الهجومي الذي وقع
قبل ساعه من الان المحليه في شبه الجزيره
بالمسيرات من نيكولايز الى جانب التطورات
الامنيه
وجديد المعارك
هل هناك تعليق او موقف اوكراني بشان
الهجوم على شبه جزيره القرم
بالفعل حسن حتى هذه هي اللحظه
جيش الاوكراني هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه لم
تعلق على هذا الاستهداف الجديد المواقع
الالكترونيه الاخباريه القريبه من السلطات
الاوكرانيه فقط نشرت ما اشرت اليه الجهات
المسؤوله في شبه جزيره القرم عن هذا
الهجوم الجديد لكنه كما قال بابا ياتي فقط
بعد يوم واحد من هجوم تبنته السلطات
الاوكرانيه لسيما المؤسسه الامنيه ممثله
بالمخابرات الاوكرانيه
وهي كانت قالت بان الهجوم الذي تعرضت له
الاخير طبعا وليس هذا اليوم هو جاء ردا
على الاستهداف الروسي لمدينه امن وسط
اوكرانيا وهذا الهجوم او الاستهداف الذي
خلف قتلى وجرح في صفوف المدنيين كانت
الرساله واضحه من المؤسسه الامنيه
الاوكرانيه عندما قالت بان شبه جزيره
القرم سيفاستوبل ايضا سوف تظل وسوف تكون
في مرمى النيران الاوكرانيه وكانت السلطات
الاوكرانيه وجهت الدعوات الى السكان
المحليين هناك في شبه جزيره القرم الى
ضروره الابتعاد عن المواقع الحساسه
الاستراتيجيه لاسيما مستودعات
الوقود وكاله السلطات الاوكرانيه بان هذه
المستودعات
توفر الوقود لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
وهو الاسطول الذي يتهم اوكرانيا بقصف
المقاطعات الاوكرانيه لاسيما المقاطعات
الجنوبيه وكانت تحدثت السلطات طيله
اليومين الماضيين عن تكثيف ضرباتها لشبه
الجزيره وتحدث كبار المسؤولين السياسيين
والعسكريين الاوكرانيين عن ان الهجوم
المضاد المرتقب الذي تتحدث عنه القوات
الاوكرانيه سيضع ش جزيره القرم اراضي
الشبه الجزيره بالكامل على سلم الاولويات
وظهرت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
يوم امس وقالت بان المعلومات الاستخباريه
الاوكرانيه تشير الى موجه نزوح كما قالت
لعائلات العسكريين الروس من شبه جزيره
القرن طيله اليومين الماضيين حسن تصاعد
الحديث الاوكراني عن شبه الجزيره وكان
الحديث مكثفا عن ان الهجوم الذي يجري
الاستعداد له ولم يعلن حتى هذه اللحظه سوف
يستهدف شبه الجزيره بشكل واضح ولا سيما
المواقع العسكريه
الروسيه وفي ضوء كل ذلك حسن يتصاعد القصف
والقصف المتبادل هنا في المناطق الجنوبيه
لاسيما المناطق المطله على شبه جزيره
القرم نتحدث عن مقاطعه خيرسون جنوبي
البلاد وهي القريبه من هنا من كولايف
القصف لا يهدا لا يتوقف بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه الحديث عن اكثر من
160 هجوما روسيا خلال الساعات الماضيه
وفقا لحاكم خيرسون على عموم المدينه هنالك
عدد من القتلى والجرحى وفقا للسلطات
المحليه في المقابل تتحدث القياده
الاوكرانيه العسكريه الجنوبيه عن ان
قواتها تكثف من قصفها لمواقع تمركز الروس
على الضفه الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر والقصف
ايضا هنا على ميكولايف على
جنوبي البلاد ونهايه حسن بعيدا عن كل ذلك
حيث الشرق المعارك محتدمه لا سيما في
بخموت في مارينكا فيكا وتقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه الجيش الاوكراني بان قواتها
تمكنت من استعاده عدد من المواقع التي
كانت تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه في باق
موتنعم
وبابا ولد حرمه مراسل الجزيره من موسكو
شكرا جزيلا لكم